[موسيقى]
حاول يكون عزيز عامل شيتو ضد السوريه
بدنا نقطع الكهرباء عن الحاره كلها
مرحبا من اكثر الاعمال المثيره للفضول هذا
العام في رمضان مسلسل للنار بالنار والسبب
جراه موضوعه واللي تتناول بعض المشاكل
اللي تواجه اللاجئين السوريين في لبنان
بجراه كبيره من بطوله النجمين عابد فهد
وكاريس بشار حاولنا نوصل فكره جدا موضوعيه
ونكون جدا وسطيين وما نكون ميالين لطرف
اكثر من طرف كونه خلفيه هذا المسلسل بيحكي
عن الصراع السوري اللبناني يلي سببه
بالاساس سياسي والناس تبنوه بس على الصعيد
الانساني بتكتشف انه حقيقه ما في خلاف على
الصعيد الانساني ولكن في رواسب عديده
والام وجروح وطبعا نزلت على المنطقه
الاساسيه اللي هي عايشه فيها بسوريا
اكيد كل السوريين بيعرفوها اسمها الشيخ
محي الدين ومن هناك انطلقت بانه مريم كيف
بتمشي وليش هيك بتمشي المسلسل المؤلف من
30 حلقه من تاليف رامي كوسا واخراج محمد
عبد العزيز يشارك فيه بالبطوله ايضا
الفنانين جورج خباز الطوني عيسى زينه مكسي
طارق تميم وكثير غيرهم ويحظى حاليا بنسبه
مشاهده عاليه وسط الكثير من الجدل على
مواقع التواصل ما بين فئات تعزز الاحداث
كواقع وافئات تصف بالمبالغه الرؤيه الفنيه
والمعالجه انا برايي انه كيف ممكن نحن
نتطرق لهذه الاشكاليه بدون ما يكون له شكل
اخباري او نيوز يعني كيف يتم معالجته
دراميا هون اهميه هذا المشروع مسلسل نار
بالنار بعتقد اول مسلسل مشترك لبناني سوري
مبرر عم يحكي عن هالصراع ما بين الشعبين
والصداقات كمان مش بس الصراعات فمسلسل
حقيقي جدا شخصيه انطوائيه عنده اسباب
وعنده تاريخه بين فقط بالحرب
وخاطفينو بوقتها السوريين فعنده اذا بدك
حقد كبير على السوريين وهذا الشيء بيترجمه
بتعاطيه مع الناجحين السوريين يلي بيكونوا
اللي بيجوا على على الحاره اللي هو ساكن
فيها انا عم بلعب شخصيه
مواطن عادي اسمه جميل كان صحافه وهو يساري
شيوعي يعني صار عنده انكسار من الثوره
بالبلد وصار عنده انكسار من انتماءه
السياسي من خطه سياسي اللي ماشي
حياه ما بصير تلعب معه
وهي اللحظه
اتاكدت انه ابليس اللي جواتي طلعوا
[موسيقى]
من الشيخ مهدي
عندك ماضي
مع السوبر جيت
[موسيقى]